depuis le début de l'invasion russe en
ukraine c'est le premier face à face
entre les chefs de la diplomatie des
deux pays
antalya en turquie
un terrain considéré comme neutre pour
des pourparlers entre les belligérants
mais avant même la rencontre le ministre
ukrainien des affaires étrangères
confie ne pas avoir grand espoir tout en
maintenant la pression sur moscou
nous appelons tous les pays européens a
abandonné le gaz et le pétrole russe
parce qu'ils ont l'odeur du sang des
ukrainiens
la russie subit de plein fouet les
sanctions et je peux vous assurer que
pour eux c'est une raison sérieuse pour
arrêter à hier
[Musique]
mais pour l'heure les avancées sont
timides les belligérants sont seulement
parvenus à négocier quelques
cessez-le-feu plus ou moins respecté par
la russie
trente cinq mille civils ont pu être
évacués de villes ukrainiennes sous les
bombardements
l'issue des pourparlers très incertain
c'est aussi un difficile je déquilibre
pour la turquie pays membre de l'otan le
président récupère douane est un allié
de kiev à qui fournit des drones de
combat mais il doit également ménager
moscou avec qui il entretient
d'importantes relations commerciales
j'espère que cette première réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères
ukrainien et russe va permettre d'ouvrir
la voie à un cessez-le-feu permanent
tout comme nous refusons d'abandonner
l'ukraine nous n'acceptons pas non plus
de participer à une chasse aux sorcières
contre le peuple russe ces intellectuels
étudiants et artistes
quelle que soit l'issue de ces
négociations
c'est d'ores et déjà un succès
diplomatique pour ratchet et hyper doan
lui qui a refusé de se joindre aux
sanctions occidentales et maintenu son
espace aérien et ses voies maritimes
ouvert à la russie